c'est logique
bien mais dès la rentrée
allez
allez tu peut fair quoc huy où la
junte a
[Musique]
moins fait le mal à la merci mon vote et
un amour merci mungo ouais t'es champion
prend quelqu'un qui veut te voir c'est
un artiste avec qui tu es super pote
apparemment un mois
atik c'est pas vrai
parce qu'il est beau et rôle bien foutu
tout pour lui et c'est lui ou pas j'ai
trouvé ça quand même
c'est vrai pas demandé à ce que
j'imagine que tu es très sollicités donc
non je suis plutôt qu'un quand je reste
dans mon boulot je regarde mon de flics
tranquille et célibataire
avait quitté chose c'est l'été qui sonne
alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
peut-être que les mecs tu aimes chanter
non ya pas que les bêtes non je ne pense
pas que les rats deux grands me
corresponde honnêtement des centaines de
kilomètres de gens dehors j'aimerais
qu'on les mette devant ceux qui
respectent le règlement je le respecte
pas correctement d'éclat des portants
donc tu grattes des clopes à gare du
nord regarde dehors même je garde du
corps gardes du corps
mais
messieurs
bonjour tout le monde est mordu donne
alors je vais essayer tilt 1k si celle
ci si petit top aldo et je le ferai
sinon belle et pourtant voilà je vous
aime je vous embrasse pas
faux
c'est prévoir
[Musique]
15e tir